un demi-dieu ancestrale vie dans ces
montagnes enchaîné depuis des
millénaires un rocher et quand ils
eurent même si ce qui se passe je
m'appelle marc à leur père j'ai 15 ans
et je viens de découvrir que je devais
sauver le monde et ça c'est devenu mon
problème
braun racing je suis professeur dans
cette université mythologie germanique
j'en ai assez d'avoir toutes ses
missions
et quoi d'autre bloqué dans une grotte
enchaîné un rocher
je vous prie il m'a renvoyé ici pour me
sauver
j'ai jamais sauvé perso j'ai pas vu ça à
la télé je vous le jure
j'ai bien vu
il est aux travaux héros de la légende
mais hommage lors de l'ultime combat est
arrivé